Künstliche Intelligenz KI ist großartig
und macht uns in vielen Bereichen das Leben
sehr viel leichter.
Doch Experten warnen davor, dass Computer
schon bald eine echte Intelligenz entwickeln
und somit in der Lage sind, sich immer weiter
selbst zu verbessern.
Dann würden sie menschliche Gehirne bei weitem
übertrumpfen und somit vielleicht sogar das
Ende der Menschheit bedeuten.
Können wir dieses Horror-Szenario vielleicht
noch abwenden und eine Super-KI kontrollierbar
gestalten, damit sie uns zumindest freundlich
gesinnt ist?!
Alles zu den Gefahren und Risiken einer möglichen
Super KI gibt es jetzt bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction.
Abonniert den Kanal, denn hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos - herzlich willkommen!
Und danke für Euren Themenvorschlag aus unserer
Telegram-Community.
Link ist in der Videobeschreibung und am Ende
des Videos.
Künstliche Intelligenz ist uns Menschen längst
nicht nur in vielen Bereichen besonders nützlich,
sondern auch jetzt schon überlegen.
Wie beispielsweise das Deep-Learning System
einer amerikanischen Firma, das menschliche
Emotionen schneller und auch genauer als die
meisten Menschen erkennen kann.
Die KI kann sogar ein echtes von einem falschen
Lächeln unterscheiden.
Deep-Learning kann aber auch Ärzteteams sehr
effektiv unterstützen.
Beispielsweise können die Algorithmen lernen,
gesunde Zellen von Krebszellen zu unterscheiden,
indem sie nach verdächtigen Merkmalen suchen.
Zudem kann die KI aber auch nach Wirkstoffen
und Medikamenten-Cocktails suchen, die individuell
für jeden Patienten am passendsten sind.
IBM hat eine KI entwickelt, die die DNA-Sequenzierung
eines Gehirntumors schneller und zuverlässiger
analysiert hat als das gesamte Team der menschlichen
Experten und Expertinnen.
Das sind aber nur zwei von mittlerweile vielen
Bereichen, in denen die KI im Wettstreit gegen
uns Menschen gewinnt.
Auch bei der Wartung von Maschinen und bei
der Analyse von juristischen Klauseln sind
uns neuronale Netzwerke mittlerweile haushoch
überlegen.
Doch nicht nur das: Einige Experten und Expertinnen
sind sich sehr sicher, dass Computer auch
echte Intelligenz entwickeln könnten.
Schon Frank Rosenblatt, der Erfinder des ersten
künstlichen Neurons “Perzeptron”, hat
die Entstehung einer Super-KI vorhergesagt.
Seine Visionen klangen damals noch nach Science-Fiction
pur, aber mit Siri und Co sind sie längst
zur Realität geworden: “Spätere Perzeptronen
werden in der Lage sein, Menschen zu erkennen
und ihre Namen zu nennen.
Gedruckte Seiten, handgeschriebene Briefe
und sogar Sprachbefehle sind in Reichweite.
Nur noch ein weiterer Entwicklungsschritt,
ein schwieriger Schritt ist notwendig, damit
ein Gerät Rede in einer Sprache hören und
sofort in Rede oder Text einer anderen Sprache
übersetzen kann.”
Doch nicht nur das: Rosenblatt sagt zudem
voraus, dass sich diese Perzeptronen irgendwann
einmal selbst reproduzieren werden und sich
sogar ihrer eigenen Existenz bewusst werden.
Seine Vision basiert auf der Annahme, dass
das Modell der künstlichen neuronalen Netze
die Grundstruktur unseres Gehirns beschreibt.
Der US-Zukunftsforscher Raymond Kurzweil prognostiziert,
dass eine KI die menschliche Intelligenz etwa
im Jahr 2045 erstmals übersteigen wird.
Der Philosoph Nick Bostrom beschreibt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir bis zum Jahr
2075 eine Maschine entwickelt haben, die uns
kognitiv ebenbürtig ist, mit 90 Prozent.
Diese könnte nicht nur mindestens so gut
wie wir strategisch planen, sondern auch logisch
denken, kreativ sein und über eine Intuition
verfügen.
Solch eine KI wäre in der Lage, sich immer
weiter zu verbessern.
Diese verbesserte KI könnte sich dann weiter
optimieren - ein ewiger Kreislauf der Selbstverbesserung
also, der Fachleuten einen eiskalten Schauer
über den Rücken laufen lässt.
Denn die Folge wäre eine Intelligenz--Explosion
und solch eine künstliche Super-Intelligenz
würde die menschliche Intelligenz komplett
in den Schatten stellen.
Auf uns würde solch eine KI wahrscheinlich
herabblicken wie wir derzeit auf Insekten.
Wenn solch eine Superintelligenz erst einmal
geschaffen ist, könnte sie nachträglich
wohl auch nicht mehr zu stoppen sein.
In der Fachsprache wird dies als “Technologische
Singularität” bezeichnet.
Es wäre die letzte Erfindung der Menschheit.
Doch es gibt auch andere Stimmen.
So zum Beispiel Yann LeCun - er ist der KI-Chef
von Facebook.
Er ist der Überzeugung, dass mit den derzeit
bekannten Technologien keine Super-KI entstehen
kann: ”Es handelt sich um ein wissenschaftliches
Problem, nicht um ein technisches”, sagt
LeCun.
“Es geht nicht darum, dass unsere Computer
nicht schnell genug wären oder die Software
ungeeignet.
Uns fehlen grundsätzliche Prinzipien”.
Somit wird es seiner Meinung nach erst einmal
bei einer sogenannten “schwachen KI” bleiben,
die eigenständig lernen kann und sehr präzise
und schnell ausgewählte Aufgaben erledigen
kann.
Eine “starke KI” dagegen wäre in der
Lage, ihr Wissen sogar zu transferieren; also
ihr Wissen von einer Aufgabe auf die nächste
zu übertragen.
Dabei könnte sich die KI sogar eigenständig
verbessern.
Dazu LeCun: “Um das zu erreichen, benötigen
wir Computerprogramme, die über so etwas
wie einen gesunden Menschenverstand verfügen,
irgendeine Form von allgemeiner Intelligenz”.
Das ist eben der große Unterschied zwischen
dem Lernverhalten von Menschen und der KI-Forschung:
Menschen, aber auch Tiere sind dazu in der
Lage, anhand weniger Daten zu lernen und das
Wissen zu generalisieren.
Anders sieht der Lernvorgang bei einem KI-System
aus: Hier werden unzählige Texte, Fotos,
Videos oder andere Daten benötigt, damit
das System auf einen spezifischen Anwendungsfall
hin optimiert werden kann.
Was aber klar ist: KI-Entscheidungen spielen
schon jetzt eine sehr große Rolle in unserer
Gesellschaft und haben somit auch immer stärkere
Auswirkungen für das menschliche Leben.
Experten und Expertinnen weltweit fordern
deswegen schon seit längerer Zeit, dass Regeln
für die Nutzung von Künstlicher Intelligenz
aufgestellt werden.
Es müssen Antworten gegeben werden auf Fragen
wie: Wollen wir Menschen uns einigen, für
welche Zwecke KI verwendet werden soll und
für welche Bereiche nicht?
Denn Maschinen übernehmen schon jetzt kognitive
Denkprozesse und könnte somit auch für feindselige
Zwecke eingesetzt werden - beispielsweise
für automatisierte Waffensysteme.
Eine andere Herausforderung in diesem Kontext
ist aber auch, dass neuronale Netzwerke einer
“Black Box” ähneln.
Somit können Berechnungen, die am Ende zu
einer Entscheidungsfindung führen, nur schwierig
oder gar nicht nachvollzogen werden.
Haben wir also jetzt bereits die Kontrolle
in gewisser Weise verloren?!
Bei YouTube zum Beispiel kann einem niemand
mehr erklären warum ein Video in den Trends
landet und ein vergleichbares nicht.
Bezüglich einer möglichen Super-Intelligenz
schlägt der Philosoph Nick Bostrom vor, diese
kontrollierbar zu gestalten.
So, dass sie uns Menschen zumindest freundlich
gesinnt ist.
Beispielsweise, indem man dem Supercomputer
Regeln einschreibt.
Doch dafür wäre ja ein ganzer Moral-Katalog
notwendig, den eine KI dann schematisch anwenden
müsste.
Effektiver wäre es vielleicht aber auch,
der KI die Fähigkeit mitzugeben, selbst moralische
Vorstellungen und ethische Werte zu entwickeln.
Ist dies ein Weg, einer möglichen Apokalypse
zu entgehen?
Die Vorstellung, dass wir uns vielleicht schon
bald den moralischen Werten einer Super-KI
unterwerfen müssen, ist dennoch reichlich
gruselig.
Mehr zum Thema gibt es hier: KI - Die letzte
Erfindung der Menschheit - Anklicken, Anschauen
und natürlich in jedem Fall Raumzeit Vlog
der Zukunft abonnieren!
Und wenn ihr nie mehr ein Video verpassen
wollt, dann klickt hierdrauf: Der unverpassbare
garantierte Telegram-Newsletter!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!
Nicht nicht geklickt?
Jetzt aber!